hey how's it going bros my name is Pippa
you're already starting aren't you [ __ ]
sorry hurts I got a little ahead of
myself welcome to five weird stuff that
I found online
all right I guess since you're a
volunteer here we're gonna start with
your item one no boots don't do it
please okay you asked for this you're
right all right so the first item of
this week is a peacock oh [ __ ] that [ __ ]
you're gonna look family don't knock it
until you've tried it anger you're gonna
look great
he's strangling me Sam help call the
police no okay let go of the hatch all
right we need the head we need Jesus
Christ I'm gonna [ __ ] kill your [ __ ]
yes yeah don't laugh at me don't laugh
the next item bros is Jason's Christ's
finger hands have you ever thought boy I
sure wish I had had some top my fingers
well look no further
nothing like the sweet touch of a finger
and I kind of like this so mesmerizing
what's that sound
could it be sponsor eagle thanks phones
read oh thanks so we have this month
loot crate which is supposed to be
fantasy I'm excited to check it out if
you bros have yours as well
get them in there well let's open them
together why don't we get straight up a
t-shirt it looks like it's from Game of
Thrones but I honestly have no idea this
could be some gang sign or some shade oh
all right a bow tie which has awesome
decorations on it I really like this one
I'm starting to not be able to fill my
fingers
I'm sure that's normal oh oh they're so
blue oh my god how do I look
I wear this to protect my virginity okay
The Princess Bride I think is a card ski
always playing cards a lot of you bros
are saying I look like the guy from this
movie ah there it is
that look like me we got a Harry Potter
bag tag 9 3/4 um hello Harry Potter
I know exactly this reference it's when
Harry ghost space Game of Thrones house
sigil magnets it that's pretty awesome
but now I can put these on my fridge and
pretend I know everything about it
oh it's a Dungeons & Dragons t-shirt
okay plus item a game of Thrones USB
disk right here old alright so that was
this month loot crate if you check out
Luke recom slash pills and usually como
him you get 10 percent off and we can
open them together just like good ol
bros if you have yours tweet at me
hashtag loop Utes and they change the
theme each month and next one is going
to be unite which is going to be all
about awesome teams like Power Rangers
and Avengers but to get the unite them
you need to order before the 19 don't
miss out on that
check out loot crate calm slash pits and
you'll get 10% off hey pretty cool I
don't know what I feel about this one
I'm sick and [ __ ] tired of these
[ __ ] baking products but this is
baking soda it looks pretty good I don't
know what I drink this [ __ ] but I
finally have an excuse to use my cool ah
ah [ __ ] oh great it smells like [ __ ]
ass
baking soda baby bottoms up
is pretty good it tastes like someone
dropped butter into my raspberry soda
pretty much the next item was suggested
by you bras and it is American American
is a pop pubic week they were originally
worn by prostitutes who had to shave off
their pubic hair to come by to pubic
lice
how did some information I would never
want to know well I know what you're
thinking how does it look on there's
only one way to find out baby oh oh oh
my god
are you [ __ ] kidding me you know I've
done a breast pump
I've electrified my nipples and I've
done a lot of weird [ __ ] on this show
but ain't no [ __ ] way I'm gonna put
these on dammit
you could also use it in your ass crack
if you want
if you thought that item was bad just
wait for the next one now I can't show
you this item because it has boobs on it
this item was suggested by you bros by
the way and it is a nipple pump it does
not say why you need the nipple pump why
do they not say what it's for start by
choosing the appropriate nipple ring it
looks like anima size 3 load the nipple
ring unto the pump
nipple ring and loaded and charged after
full erection has been achieved roll
nipple ring unto nipple and remove
nipple pump my nipple look like it's
about to pop let's keep pumping maybe
it's there what happened to this channel
okay Bryce I'm so sorry hope you enjoyed
this episode if you did hit that like
button keep suggesting me stuff or by
weight stuff online it's really enjoy
this show and I'm Bobbi Brossart as well
don't forget to check it out loot crate
calm such pills and I'll see you bros in
the next episode as always stay awesome
press
ladies my name is Chuck's upstage
welcome is that how he does it